ah ah
deux orphelins après à changer leur
destin a lancé hier des grands départs
vont embarquer vers la plus fascinante
des cités
rien de les préparer à rencontrer le
véritable maître de venise
je m'appelle sibiu je connais les
moindres recoins de la ville voici mon
antre et mon équipe et notre butin nous
mettons la main sur certains des objets
qui dorment dans les coffres des
palettes en osier filtrant la nuit notre
intermédiaire s'appelle barbarossa ses
pions qui vient de nous contacter et
chez un client le castillet khl par
l'odeur de kurt angle
je voudrais que vous derbier pour moi
trésor
que je cherche depuis de nombreuse
on cherche la légendaire elle du lion
parti sur les traces d'adn incroyable
trésor dans un monde où le mystère et la
magie vous attendent à chaque coin de
rue ce noël
partez à l'aventuré non
le voleur de venise